from shoe ends to a Vegas longshot atop
Vegas oddsmaker says Paula Dean has the
worst chance of winning Dancing with the
Stars I mean come on 100 to 1 but Paul
is used to beating the odds and Samantha
Harris got the first chance to see Paula
at work before her first dance tonight
we're gonna have a full conversation on
that floor while we s-sorry talking
they're calling yourselves team
buttercup
their secret weapon ventriloquism Paula
says her memory isn't what it used to be
and she's forgetting steps but she's got
Louisa lean on he's 25 years younger and
rejoining the pros after a three-year
hiatus
what made you compel to do the show you
know my family my team everybody was so
excited they said Paulie you've lost 40
pounds you can do this mama you know
these costumes can tend to get a little
bit skimpy so how about grandma honey
okay all right and what we don't want to
make people sick so the first is there
an elevator no granny no no at 68 this
granny isn't slowing down her healthiest
cookbook yet Paula Deen cuts the fat is
out now that's the right nut butter pie
Oh Oh in the cookbook
I could eat it and I would never know I
would never know why haven't I had a
piece of that yeah cause you won't let
me quit Dancing long enough to go into
the kitchen
you